seventy-five million Americans are
feeling the deep freeze left behind by a
deadly winter storm that swept through
the Midwest and Northeast at least four
deaths are blamed on the storm system
over the weekend areas of New York State
got as much as 20 inches of snow parts
of Ohio Pennsylvania and Vermont got up
to 18 inches temperatures across across
the Northeast this morning are in single
digits or below zero
yikes wind chills right here in New York
City are just 15 degrees below zero and
listen to this it's negative 25 in
Burlington Vermont so we're feeling
feeling balmy here
Omar Villafranca is in Killington
Vermont with a look at the bitter cold
Oh mark bitter is the word yeah you can
need to jump up and down go ahead good
morning from Killington Vermont where
the temperatures are below zero the wind
chill factor well below zero in fact we
were gonna try to go to the peak of the
mountain here in Killington but the snow
cats froze so we're here at the base of
this ski resort the temperatures up
there are actually much colder now all
of this may look Pleasant it may look
nice but this storm that way from
California to New England was dangerous
and deadly the storm buried parts of the
Northeast in snow and ice in upstate New
York the Hudson River froze over people
in Glen Falls New York near the Vermont
border spent the day digging out for
more than a foot and a half of snow and
plows could barely keep up with the
whiteout conditions on interstate 87 in
gray Maine people raised to clear around
eight inches of snow before the Arctic
temps froze everything you do a little
bit at a time go back in warm up come
back out later in Connecticut what we're
particularly worried about is with the
icy conditions and what that means to
the electric grid the snow sleet and
freezing rain knocked out power to more
than 20,000 buildings a utility worker
was killed Sunday when a tree fell on
him while he was trying to restore
service the storm was deadly from its
onset in Kansas a snow plow driver died
Saturday morning when his vehicle rolled
off the road and it created a scare in
Chicago when the United Airlines jet
slid off the icy runway after landing at
O'Hare Airport next thing we know we are
off the runway and stuck in snow in
Missouri slick surfaces triggered this
15 car crash on Interstate 55 shutting
down the road for hours the effects of
the storm reached as far south as
Alabama at least six people were hurt in
an apparent ef-2 tornado winds topping
135 miles an hour significantly damaged
several buildings outside of Montgomery
it was just shake shake shake shake you
look up and everything's going good news
is the worst of the storm is over the
system has now moved offshore and for
people here in Vermont it's something
they've heard many times if they're
gonna be outside whether they're gonna
be walking a dog or skiing they've got
to take a lot of breaks hydrate
especially with warm liquids and go
inside to take breaks back to you guys
in the warm 68 degrees studio I'm sorry
Omar thank you so much yes get inside
quickly thank you